virgin hotels las vegas is getting ready
to open its doors
this week can you believe it that is a
quick transformation just a year ago was
the hard rock hotel
let's check in with christian who's live
outside the property with what we can
expect when the red carpet rolls out hey
christian
hey kirsten well thursday will be the
big day that's the day when the guests
will be able to come to the property
check in
and basically explore this resort now
virgins hotels las vegas promises
that this will be more of a modern day
oasis with 1500 rooms
and a very unique decor throughout the
entire
resort now they're starting on a good
note because let me tell you the hotel
will open with complimentary
self-parking
no resort freeze and they will have free
wi-fi i know many of you will be very
excited about that now another cool
feature is their app
it's called lucy and this is where
guests can basically check in and use it
as a mobile room key
order room service and overall have a
contact
let's stay here on the resort now
virgin's hotel is located
off the las vegas strip where the former
hard rock hotel used to operate so this
site
will definitely look very familiar to
many folks here in the valley
now also the property we're told will
feature a 5
acre swimming pool i know you and i are
very excited about that especially
with summer just around the corner but i
understand that the pool and the day
club will not open this week
it will open a little bit further on uh
in the month of may but after the break
we will be taking you
inside the property to show you a little
bit about the decor that they have here
so you can know exactly what to expect
when you get here